Watch as we knit warm, double the
ear flaps that can be added to the
hats in our Ear Flap Hat Collection.
Start with an open cast on
with waste yarn and ravel cord.
Knit the straight section
according to the pattern.
Set the carriage to hold.
On the carriage side.
Start the short row decreases
by pulling needles to hold.
Add weight and use your fingers to make
sure all of the stitches knit correctly.
Start the short row increases
by putting needles opposite the
carriage back into working position.
Again, use weight and your fingers to
ensure that everything knits properly.
Knit straight according to your pattern.
Join the two edges by picking
up the open cast on stitches.
Wrap the tail of yarn around the
first needle, pull out the Ravel
cord and remove the scrap yarn.
Knit one row.
This will make it easier
to hang the flaps.
You can always remove this extra
row if you decide you don't want it.
And scrap off.
Knit the second flap and
you're ready to knit your hat.